my next guest is a living legend in the
world of racing
he's a seven-time nascar champion and
five of those wins
back to back to back to back that's
right
something that's never been done before
and now at 45 years old he is a rookie
again this time in the world of indie
race car driving so everybody welcome my
friend jimmy johnson
i know it's so weird we can't hug yet
we're not there yet but we're getting
close
soon i know yes how are you i'm
fantastic i hope you are too
i am i'm doing all right and you were
here like a year ago i believe and you
announced you're retiring so you were
like nope just kidding
you're like those musicians that are
like it's my farewell tour but it's not
it's not no and i
i was thinking about it before i came
out and i knew you're going to ask me
about that and
you know i don't think like yourself i
don't think you can ever stop singing or
playing or being with
the band so i what i was ready to step
away from was the grind
of the 38 races a year that i did for 20
plus years so
kind of like being out on the road i
guess for you and touring and stuff
but now i've have a much shorter
schedule for racing and having a blast
doing it
so for the idiots in the room what's the
difference between
nascar and indy i know i've been to both
i can see there's a difference but what
is the
like the biggest difference you know
from an aesthetic standpoint
one's a big sedan vehicle and then the
indy car is this little lightweight
like rocket ship that you drive and
literally the weight of the vehicle
um would make the indy car like a sports
car and then the nascar vehicle would be
much more like an suv
so wait does that make it more or less
dangerous uh
danger's probably pretty equal but the
experience in driving the car is much
different the indy car
takes a lot of aggression and the car
doesn't ever give up like you can't hurt
the tires you can't hurt the brakes and
the intensity is much higher driving it
with a nascar vehicle it's a bigger car
you can wear the brakes out in a race
you can hurt the tires and you have to
finesse it a bit more
okay so has this ever been done has
anybody ever gone from nascar especially
on such a
huge successful level and then been like
no i'm gonna try andy has anyone ever
done that i
there may have been somebody in the 70s
i'm told but
yeah nothing i've never heard of that
we've had more open-world drivers try
nascar in recent time
uh but but really not the other
direction and honestly this was a
childhood dream of mine
growing up on the west coast indycar
during my generation
um was the big sport to you know want to
race in and aspire to be in so
my my world changed when my manufacturer
that i drove for said hey look we're not
going to be in any car any longer you
need to move to north carolina and go
stock car racing and my path was set
then
wow yeah come back to it now it's super
cool i know
i was good and this is it sounds like a
movie like i was i was
reading about you last night i was like
this sounds like a a great plot for a
movie by the way
i was like it's just i i would watch um
so are are you starting to see that your
girls are daredevils like you
and does it scare you because it's not
you it's them it's true it
is far harder watching my children do
things that i love to do and i know that
they're into than me
participating in myself but we're a very
active family and
skiing my girls both ride horses and are
jumping horses we have dirt bikes and
go-karts all the things to maybe
possibly end up with a broken collar
bone correct but i want to think that
the combination of
mom's cautious approach to things and
then my crazy approach will balance them
out
okay balance is good so how does it feel
to have fans back in the stands
it's been great i mean i think at one
point in time
i was very eager just to work again and
to be back
on the track and know that our sport was
on television
and then fans have slowly been coming
back and now with the direction covet
has gone
to actually have you know half of a
stadium filled full of fans is such a
great sight and the energy that they
bring is
the energy is crazy i've been to andy
and nascar and it is nuts
it is like that you cannot help i have
no idea generally what's going on and
i'm just like wow
because it's just a good time it's like
a country music festival
you know you have to know the music
you're just having a good time um so and
and fans they get to vote is it on your
car
the color of your car yeah so there's a
really neat opportunity if people uh
want to learn more about it go to
carvana.com and
of course we're always trying to figure
out how to integrate with the fans and
yeah now that fans are back in the
stands
um we just want them to know that they
can have ownership in a car that i'm
going to race at some point
during the season so we'll have five
times in total and there'll be three
more opportunities left for the fans to
pick what i what my race car looks like
wait so what colors so far then like
what are what do you have any
because green is a great color kelly
green is a great i understand
but carvana blue is a better color for
my situation
okay well you know what i like blue too
though because it's the winning ribbon
it's the it's the blue is the winning
one yeah you're projecting i like it
i like it but kelly green's still a
great color um so you can see jimmy
johnson race at the gmr grand prix at
the indianapolis motor speedway this
saturday may 15th you got to check it
out
um also be sure to check out jimmy in
the booth for nbc's coverage of the
indianapolis 500 on sunday may 30th want
more fun
stuff i thought so check out these
videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure